[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de tv fil 78 voici
les titres en images de ce 20 avril 2010
est lancée en 2010 le programme
d'extension de parly 2 avance à terme
l'extension doit permettre à
l'installation de 15 nouvelles enseignes
et offrir aux clients un nouveau cinéma
de 12 salles nous ferons le point la
menace terroriste plane sur la fin de
campagne présidentielle du côté des
républicains la thématique est
dorénavant centrale hier à voisins le
bretonneux jean frédéric poisson député
des yvelines porte-parole de françois
fillon est revenu sur les propositions
de son candidat et puis loisirs un
nouveau parc dédié au trampoline bien
ouverts à maurepas
la spécificité de cet urban jump un
parcours ninja warrior un parcours
d'épreuves physiques le seul
en ile-de-france la campagne
présidentielle va donc se terminer
officiellement demain vendredi à minuit
du côté du front national ont mise
notamment sur les plus jeunes selon les
enquêtes d'opinion le front national
serait devenu le premier parti chez les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans pourquoi sont-ils
séduit par le discours de marine le pen
nous avons suivi jérémy gauthier
militants depuis 2012 dans le
département le reportage est signée
michael almy d'or un tiers des jeunes
âgés de 18 à 25 ans devraient voter
front national ce dimanche 23 avril
sur le terrain certains n'hésitent pas à
s'engager c'est le cas de jérémy gouchie
25 ans ce diplômé en master de
communication vient d'être élu
secrétaire départemental de la jeunesse
fn dans les yvelines pour lui marine le
pen représente la meilleure réponse pour
la jeunesse vraiment de toutes les
expériences par lesquels je suis passé
les stages à l'étranger
le fait de chercher une alternance l'apl
comment payer son loyer avec des
salaires minimes
voilà vraiment parler de la galère
étudiante comment s'en sortir
pour convaincre les indécis jérémy des
pousses des tracts dans les boîtes aux
lettres 7 jours sur 7 pendant plus de
trois heures le militant les distribue
également sur les marchés ou à la sortie
des transports en commun en garde une
proximité humaine avec les gens au delà
du programme bonjour monsieur journée au
delà du programme
on va apporter un aspect non on va
humaniser notre programme on a essayé de
l'expliquer d'avoir une proximité avec
les gens pour qu'ils puissent parfois
mieux comprendre un discours frontiste
qui ne passe pas forcément chez tous les
jeunes
je pense que c'est un peu extrême pour
pour l'âge parce que je pense qu'à 18 24
ans vous 18 25 ans on n'a pas tout vu
dans la vie donc je pense que c'est un
peu jeune mais c'est bien qu'ils se
mettent à la politique c'est c'est
important en 2012 le parti de marine le
pen avait recueilli 12 4% des suffrages
au premier tour des présidentielles dans
le département cette année jérémy espère
que ce score va atteindre 22% grâce à la
mobilisation des jeunes dans les
yvelines
l'arrestation de deux hommes soupçonnés
de préparer une attaque terroriste pour
fragiliser la campagne présidentielle a
remis ce sujet au coeur des débats à
quelques jours du scrutin si la ou les
personnalités ciblées sont encore
inconnues le nom de françois fillon a
été évoqué à plusieurs reprises mercredi
soir à foison le bretonneux se dérouler
l'un des derniers meetings yvelinois de
la campagne des républicains
le sujet a été largement abordée sur
place osman vendeurs des à quelques
jours du premier tour le terrorisme
s'invite dans la campagne menaces sur
les candidats menace sur le bon
déroulement du scrutin les candidats
durcissent le ton pour répondre à l'une
des principales préoccupations des
français
la sécurité est pour jean frédéric
poisson candidat à la primaire de la
droite est aujourd'hui porte parole de
françois fillon
le discours des républicains est le seul
à répondre à ses attentes
françois fillon adapté a pris des
positions sur l'islamisme radical qui
sont extrêmement claires elles sont
d'ailleurs les plus claires de tous les
candidats en présence dans le cadre de
cette élection j'observe que même le
front national a considérablement reculé
dans sa rhétorique sur c'est sur ces
sujets de manière d'ailleurs assez
incompréhensible enfants ça les regarde
très clairement nous sommes aujourd'hui
en situation de manque d'effectifs de
manque de matériel pour la playlist pour
la gendarmerie en particulier et donc le
renforcement de la sécurité des français
et leur protection passe par une
augmentation des effectifs de police de
gendarmerie de douane pour le contrôle
des frontières et tous les matériels qui
doivent êtres qui doivent accompagner
ses différentes missions
lors de cette réunion publique à voisins
le bretonneux un autre député des
yvelines pascal thévenot est aussi venu
porter le programme de son candidat dans
ce domaine ils constatent effectivement
une demande forte de la part des
électeurs en général ce qu'on nous
demande dans les réunions publiques
séparer de la famille de l'emploi et de
la sécurité
c'est même le maire qui parle c'est vrai
que j'attends beaucoup d'avoir retrouvé
un état de droit où chacun
koné ses devoirs tolérance zéro impunité
0 françois fillon envisage entre autres
d' abaisser la majorité pénale à 16 ans
liant la lutte contre le terrorisme à
celle contre le totalitarisme islamique
il entend aussi déchoir de leur
nationalité les combattants partis à
l'étranger
autant de propositions qui selon un
récent sondage et lab ne le placez
néanmoins qu'à la troisième place des
candidats les plus crédibles en matière
de sécurité
derrière marine le pen emmanuel macron
ont quitté la politique et nous partons
au chesnay où se trouve l'un des
premiers centres commerciaux de france
inauguré en 1969 par les deux est en
pleine rénovation depuis 2010 après
avoir construit une sortie sur la
départementale 186 avec de nouveaux
parkings la structure vient de lancer la
dernière phase de son chantier une
extension avec de nouveaux magasins
livraison programmée pour la fin de
l'année
c'est le point final d'un projet à 250
millions d'euros débuté en 2010 la
rénovation du centre commercial parly ii
implantée aux chaînés depuis 1969 étant
sa dernière phase 180 ouvriers
travaillent actuellement sur une liaison
de 10 mille mètres carrés qui permettra
une circulation boucle dans le centre et
d'accueillir des magasins
supplémentaires derrière nous il y aura
un grand rectangle qui accueillera sur
deux niveaux l'extension du monoprix est
aussi une cellule pour accueillir la
poissonnerie et derrière dans l'angle la
partie longue duel se trouvera donc
cette connexion entre deux partis du
centre avec ses quinze enseignes
supplémentaires
le lifting s'opère également à
l'extérieur du centre commercial les
façades extérieures construite au siècle
dernier sont actuellement en cours de
restauration
les façades rond bien commencer à vous
aurez un aperçu au niveau de la façade
du bhv c'est à la fois un
une alliance des motifs historiques de
pas d'eux qu'on appelle les
moucharabiehs il y a aussi des plaques
de mbk en céramique sur les façades
principales et enfin sur certains angles
un habillage en pierre de vals grise
bleue pour habiller les façades
notamment côté voie publique avec ces
travaux la structure qui attire déjà 12
millions de visiteurs par an espère en
accueillir 3 millions de plus à
l'horizon 2018 redonné en fait à paris
n'ose son rayonnement régional et à les
capter une clientèle alors de paris
16ème en passant par saint germain en
laye jouy en josas montfort l'amaury pas
à pas une concurrence notamment renforcé
avec un beau grenelle 1 vélizy un
plaisir à saint germain en laye donc
voilà fort de cette rénovation des
parties communes et parties extérieures
des façades et cette offre
supplémentaire de 15 en scène
supplémentaire
on est vraiment un mais pour les
prochaines décennies l'inauguration
officielle est programmée pour la fin
novembre par les 2 proposera à partir de
cette date 117 mille mètres carrés de
surfaces commerciales et plus de 200
magasins à deux ans de fêter ses 50 ans
un autre chantier c'est un plaisir à
présent 80 logements vont voir le jour
l'ancienne gendarmerie va les accueillir
le bâtiment vacant depuis 2004
appartenait à l'état il accueillera neuf
logements les autres seront construits
sur le terrain d'un hectare attenant au
bâtiment militaire c'est le promoteur
crédit agricole immobilier qui va mener
ce chantier livraison prévue pour le
début de l'année 2020 on écoute la maire
de la commune il y aura à la fois 50 %
de logements sociaux
moi je préfère dire des logements aidés
puisque aujourd'hui vous savez que
énormément de population française peut
accéder aux logements sociaux surtout
les jeunes
nous avons aussi ce respect du maintien
des 25 % de logements sociaux sur
l'ensemble de la collectivité
aujourd'hui nous sommes entre 25 et 26 %
donc dans toute mise en place de
nouvelles habitat sur la collectivité
est important de gérer cette intégration
des logements sociaux pour garder notre
équilibre et 25% en sachant que nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait une mixité dans
l'habitat parce qu'aujourd'hui n'est
plus question de faire des quartiers
sociaux entièrement propos recueillis
par mélanie poquet du sport
à présent avec un tournoi unss de
handball qui était organisée mercredi à
plaisir le lycée jean vilar de la
commune a affronté à cette occasion le
lycée de l'académie de paris et puis un
autre également de créteil l école est
une habituée de ce tournoi elle s'est
déjà qualifiée en 2012 pour les
championnats de france unss la meilleure
équipe cadette du département at elle à
nouveau réussi un tel exploit la réponse
le titre de champion interacadémiques de
handball s'est joué ce mercredi 19 avril
à plaisir l'association sportive du
lycée jean vilar recevait au gymnase
d'une école hassler les lycées de paris
et de montereau objectif décrocher une
qualification pour les championnats de
france unss
douze élèves plaisir wa actuellement en
seconde et en première ont participé à
la compétition était là le niveau il est
moins élevé qu'en club quand même mais
il reste quand même bon sur l'équipe de
paris nous on est un peu au dessus
physiquement aussi
mais sinon après ces attaques le mans ça
va ça joue bien c'est assez important
quand même même si c'est un championnat
qui est moins fort que ce qu'on pratique
en club c'est quelque chose qu'on tient
à coeur parce qu'on est des compétiteurs
et on veut absolument gagner ce tournoi
est aussi l'occasion de mettre en
pratique les deux heures de cours
dispensées chaque mercredi depuis début
septembre dans le lycée moi je suis dans
le questionnement je les fait réfléchir
sur le jeu je les fais intervenir dans
les temps morts
je les fais intervenir à la mi temps
pour avoir leurs ressentis savoir ce
qu'il faut changer et cetera sais pas
c'est pas moi qui donne toutes les
informations j'essaie de les mobiliser à
l'heure au sens tactique et réfléchie du
jeu pour qu'il y ait un vrai
apprentissage pas l'équipe de plaisir a
finalement terminé deuxième après sa
défaite 23 9 contre le lycée montereau
un classement qui leur permet d'accéder
au championnat de france unss
la compétition devrait se dérouler fin
mai à lima
ouvert depuis le 25 mars ce dernier à
maurepas à l'urban john propose des
activités autour du trampoline un espace
ludique notamment pour s'amuser en
famille nicolas landry a suivi la
famille bou said le reportage
si le combat semble déséquilibré contre
son fils elias le duel contre sofia sa
fille semble plus compliquée pour linda
j'ai réussi à tenir l'équipe parce que
je suis plus costaud mais utilisant
mieux s'ils ont réussi à me faire tomber
une fois et je t'invite les eaux vais
mettre fin une fois et et tu m'a fait
tomber
oui yazid et linda sont venus avec leurs
deux enfants pour passer une matinée à
l'urban job de maurepas plusieurs
activités dunk free jump ou encore un
parcours ninja warriors un défi relevé
par sofia
j'ai fait le parcours j'ai fait
l'élastique
j'ai fait les paniers de basket
je fais des celtes sur le trampoline
j'ai sauté au trampoline on peut citer
le moyen de passer un moment en famille
avec les enfants noah 4 qui est assez
ludique est assez nouveau et surtout et
trampoline c'est un truc est super sympa
quoi et on n'a pas la petite enfer c'est
justement en constatant cette demande qu
aurélien guillot a ouvert ce centre le
25 mars dernier
ancien trampolinistes du club des
clayes-sous-bois il a dû arrêter suite à
plusieurs blessures
aujourd'hui il vit sa passion autrement
quand le concept est arrivé il ya un peu
moins de deux ans maintenant en france
c'est vrai que je me suis tout de suite
intéressé et
voilà j'ai tout de suite cherché à
développer cette activité là c'est déjà
une activité à côté et que j'ai que j'ai
cédé pour pouvoir écrire cet article
après ces efforts la famille boussaïd
peut rentrer à la maison avec des bons
souvenirs en hauteur culture pour
refermer ce journal avec un spectacle à
découvrir les 21 et 22 avril la ferme
des animaux lors d'une révolte les
animaux chasse les fermiers pour créer
alors république le classique de
l'écrivain britannique george orwell
retrace l'arrivée de staline au pouvoir
l'oeuvre est revisitée par la compagnie
in cauda et la jeune troupe de la ferme
de bel ébat c'est donc à découvrir les
21 et 22 avril
lundi nous vous proposerons une édition
spéciale consacrée aux résultats de
l'élection présidentielle rendez vous à
partir de 18 heures et pour les premiers
chiffres dans les yvelines n'oubliez pas
également à nos réseaux sociaux dès le
dimanche soir à partir de 20h très belle
soirée demain vendredi vous avez rendez
vous avec nicolas kirillovitch pour une
nouvelle édition de l'hebdo
[Musique]